nos preguntan convierte la siguiente
ecuación de la forma punto pendiente a
la forma pendiente intersección en otras
palabras si se reescribe la ecuación en
la forma es igual a mx más b cuáles son
los valores de m&b ok y tengo esta
ecuación de kim y e más 11 es igual a 5
por x + 2 así que déjame sacar por acá
mi bloc de notas mi libreta de apuntes
para poder trabajar este problema y
fíjate bien que aquí ya tenemos esta
ecuación de más 11 es igual a 5 que
multiplica a x + 2 y si te das cuenta
con esta forma de escribir a la recta
punto pendiente podemos fijarnos de una
manera muy sencilla que está este de
aquí es su pendiente y bueno también
podemos fijarnos de una manera muy
sencilla que esta recta pasa y déjame
cambiar de color esta recta pasa por el
punto menos dos coma menos 11 y déjame
ponerlo aquí pasa por el punto menos
-11 y esto es porque recuerdan que la
forma punto pendiente se ve como la
pendiente que multiplica a x - x 1 o
dicho de otra manera a x menos la
coordenada en x del punto por el que
pasa es decir menos 2 x menos es más 2 y
esto es igual a menos de 1 es decir de
menos la coordenada y del punto por el
que pasa es decir menos 11 y bueno lo
que nosotros queremos es pasar de esta
ecuación a la forma pendiente
intersección con el eje de la siesta o
lo que es lo mismo pendiente ordenada al
origen y que bueno claro como sabemos es
de la forma que es igual a m por equis
hey ahora para llegar a esta forma lo
que voy a hacer es trabajar con esta
ecuación y utilizar una manipulación
algebraica para encontrar esta ecuación
en la forma pendiente intersección con
el eje de las 10 y entonces seguramente
te imaginarás que m la pendiente seguirá
siendo este 5 que tenemos aquí y bueno
como te imaginarás lo primero que vamos
a hacer es distribuir este 5
multiplicando a estos dos por lo tanto
vamos a hacerlo me va a quedar a más 11
10 más 11 esto es igual a 5 por x lo
cual me va a dar 5 x déjame poner racing
5 x más 5 x 2 lo cual es 10 5 x más 10
ahora si te das cuenta estamos muy cerca
de tener la forma pendiente ordenada el
origen que queremos lo único que nos
hace falta hacer es quitar este 11 del
lado izquierdo de esta ecuación y para
eso lo que voy a hacer es restar 11 de
ambos lados de esta ecuación de tal
forma que si restó 11
y resto 11 acá me va a quedar algo de la
forma pie es igual a algo por equis más
otra cosa que es justo lo que queremos
despejar allí y por lo tanto voy a
restar 11 y este y éste se van y
entonces me voy a quedar con james es
igual y de este lado derecho me va a
quedar 5 veces x éste se bajan 5 veces x
menos 1 porque si te das cuenta 10 - 11
es menos 1 y justo aquí ya tenemos la
respuesta y es igual a 5 x menos 1 y
está del lujo porque es el momento de
sacar el navegador de internet que lo
tengo justo por aquí y es hora de poner
la respuesta y es igual a 5 por x más y
bueno como aquí tengo más voy a poner un
menos uno de tal manera que más x menos
sea menos y ya justo aquí está mi
respuesta
vamos a comprobar que la respuesta esté
bien y de lujo estamos bien